à New York une intervention très
remarquée tout à l'heure à la tribune
des Nations Unies celles de Madame
Simone Veil l'ancienne présidente du
Parlement européen appelée d en faveur
des droits de l'homme et la surtout
interpellé longuement tous les pays qui
n'ont pas signé la charte relative au
droit de l'homme Paul Nahon à New York
il y a une grave
lacune dans le monde les violations des
droits de l'homme et notamment la tortue
pour aussi faire pression sur les pays
qui n'avaient pas encore ratifié la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et
puis en marge de cette réunion la
décision prise hier par les Soviétiques
de libérer tous les prisonniers
politiques
c'est très important
effectivement on a vu depuis quelques
mois un certain nombre de
Juifs d'une soviétiques ou de dissidents
politiques pour lesquels depuis des
années nous faisions compagne qui ont
été soit autorisés à immigrés soit quand
tu étais libérées de prison ou des camps
ils étaient mais on reste encore et le
fait qu'il y ait une détente Est-Ouest
permet d'avoir un climat qui se prête
davantage un dialogue même pour ce qui
concerne les conflits régionaux mais le
secrétaire général des Nations Unies a
été très actif à profiter à su profiter
de cette nouvelle opportunité et je
crois qu'on ne peut pas tout de même
souligner ce qui a été réalisé
un peu son prestige oui d'ailleurs
imprimait le prix Nobel de la peine à
consacré puisque ce sont les casques
bleus qui l'ont obtenu certains
pensaient que ce serait secrétaire
général des Nations unies mais je crois
que c'est en tout cas un petit peu
l'intervention le fait qu'on reconnaît
la possibilité le fait que lorsque les
Nations Unies interviennent ils peuvent
favoriser la paix et ils l'ont fait